hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot at
e3 2017 joining Miguel and myself is
will and Anoop here to show us agents of
mayhem guys how's your show bin oh it's
been great
yeah well I'm super excited to show the
game and it's going really well
yes so will you're gonna be driving yeah
I'm gonna be driving showing off I'm a
I'm like like a noob said we're just uh
we're going into the homestretch here
with agents coming out in August 15th so
just really looking forward to showing
off to all the consumers at e3 for the
first three consumer show yeah it's been
a really sort of exciting year and that
like there is the mix of the regular
developers games industry journalists
and things and now the public finally
getting their hands on it
what's the reception been like it's been
really positive I mean people have been
really excited about seeing all the
stuff we have they're starting to see a
lot of the connections to Saints Row
that we've had in the past and they
really really respond to the agents of
the humour I mean I have to ask because
this game it's not like a Saints Row
sequel but obviously gat is back yes yes
uh what is the relationship between the
two so in Saints Row get out of Hell
Johnny Gat basically gets a choice from
God about what he wants to do and one of
the choices the player can make is to
remake the universe in a new way and
agents mayhem is essentially our version
of that that universe that's been
created so he ends up being a soul cop
so Seoul South Korea cop and and so when
you see him in a Jame him that's his
background awesome alright so what's
happening here so here we're being
introduced to August got one of legions
lieutenants Legion is sort of the bad
guy of the whole ancient age to me
mayhem universe they have an incredible
acronym yes
League of Evil gentlemen intent on
obliterating nations correct yes so good
everything has to have acronym ah so
this is a lieutenant you'll face sort of
in the middle of the game but the idea
he might look like a pop star you
recognize and one of the cool things is
our our audio guys actually wrote pop
music for him that you'll hear in the
game it's really catchy but also pretty
terrible yeah
there is toast
all right the one major takeaways I got
when I first played this was it's very
much inspired by 80s cartoons but with a
very mature themed angle yes more about
that yeah I mean I think kind of the way
you know I grew up on these a lot of the
guys at the studio did other people as
well and the way I look at it is like if
they kept making cartoons for ourselves
this is what you might have to see in
the end oh yeah so it's not for kids for
sure and you know there's definite lot
of violence a lot of foul language and
other things so so here we see wills
choosing his squad you have a you know
12 ages that you can pick from and you
want to pick three at a time and you
take them into the city and you play as
all three of them at one time you can
swap between them as you're in the field
so how do you know how to like create
the best squad can you prioritize you
know some things of another so he's gone
full hulks yeah so all the aides have
their own skins too that you unlock as
you play through the game in terms of
the squad selection you it's really
about your personal choices how you play
the game what kind of agents you respond
to what kind of abilities you really
like and then you have gadgets and the
others they level up and you can each
put points in different stats and those
will allow you to sort of customize the
squad to your play style it's kind of
reminiscent to me as a little bit like
Mass Effect 2 and that you had this big
cast of characters and you could only
take 3 arrow into the field essentially
what's it like sort of summarize you
have to write for the characters house
characters must interact and that must
be a sort of pin board with like string
red string going from one to the other
have a very big data base that our
writers got very familiar with to keep
track of everything and one of the cool
things is you're playing through a
mission you can since you can pick any
of the 12 characters we had to write
specific lines for each of the
characters when they respond and that's
a lot of fun is just sort of hearing how
they respond to different things in the
game oh wow so she's getting run over
yeah no that's the other agents have our
unique entries into those vehicles
they're very much based on their
characters so jewel that wills playing
on right now is she's our fashionista
engineer so she has a turret that she
deploys and that's her main way of
taking out Legion and we mouse in the
kind of storefronts with the Korean
lettering that
that is because the the game is set in
Seoul Korea yes correct
so Legion has attacked all over the
world but right now the Ministry of
pride one of the seven ministries of
Legion they are focusing their efforts
in Seoul and the point of the game is to
basically find out why dr. Babylon and
his ministry are here and what they're
up to and then then basically stop them
so here we'll select an Oni whose former
Yakuza hit man and he's really good at
critical hits and fearing as enemies so
they put them in a panic mode and then
they can take advantage of that which so
that the game is designed in a way that
that you're encouraged to decide on a
threesome early on or is it pretty
forgiving if you if you're feeling like
a certain group of characters just
aren't working for you yeah no we
absolutely want people to experiment to
try out different characters so you know
if something's not working go back to
the arc switch out for a different three
they if you're if you have some
characters that are lower level when you
play with them they it they will
actually increase at a faster rate so
they can catch up to the ones that
you're already playing with and
basically the idea is we we want people
to try different configurations and
figure out what works best for them well
it also kind of depends on what type of
gameplay style like what you're trying
to get out of the game if you're just
looking for having a story experience if
you're looking to learn about the
characters you're probably going to ramp
the difficulty down because there's what
ten different different or 15 different
others 15 that and then we actually
unlock more as you get higher higher up
and so you can scale the difficulty
depending on how much experience that
you want you want to get out of it but
if you don't want if you just want to
get this story then you have it on the
lowest level you get a minimal amount of
experience but you get the you get the
story from the game and that's all about
personality when you're choosing the
agents you want play as if you're doing
the higher difficulties you really have
to be more strategic about what which
guys you're picking how the squads going
to relate to each other and how you can
combine their ability
one other I'm going to piggyback off
Miguel's question there how do you are
you gonna have all of the make agents
playable from the gecko or do you have
to introduce them slowly you know I mean
I imagine onboarding yeah that's it's
definitely yeah it got overwhelming um
when we saw on play test so what we we
have three agents that are you're
introduced you right from the beginning
fortune hardtack and Hollywood and then
once you get past the first sort of
sequence you get access to about half of
them then you play their unlock mission
you can learn more about them how other
abilities work how their weapons work
and then you can choose whether you want
to continue with them or or go back to
other ones and then as you go through
further in the game will unlock more of
them over time but by the time you're in
the middle of the game you'll have
access to all of them I remember playing
the scene yesterday it was actually one
of my favorite scenes when you got to
here you got to hear a God react to the
fact that you were stealing one of his
cars yes
I can aimed one of his cars yeah yes yes
yeah exactly yeah we we have got sort of
interact with you quite a bit during
these missions because we want you by
the end of it to feel like yeah you
really want to kill this guy yeah me how
would you compare sort of the the type
of humor um this game has versus like
the last couple Saints Row games so what
I would say is the I feel like the humor
is more character based and more based
in the genre of the game that we're
making here but it still got a lot of
the over to the top cut we don't take
ourselves too seriously the agents own
that's like take everything too
seriously but they understand they have
a job to do and they're they're gonna do
it as we see here crafting ready
I've been collecting things and what can
we crack so you know as you kill enemies
you'll get these sort of crafting
materials and you can use that to craft
new gadgets for the agents these are
things that will either modify how their
special abilities work their weapon
works or sort of give them a passive
ability and that's a big part of the
customization aspect of the the game is
figuring out what gadget loadout you
want for the agent on top of which one's
worked well together so not only are you
levelling up the individual agents but
there's also leveling up the agency as a
whole the arc
doing that because you have a given
vehicle bay you have weapons of am
abilities there's a lot of leveling up
and really customizing what agents you
want to play ads so getting to what
Miguel was talking about earlier we're
just about that hit that we're about to
find Tiffany here yes anyway this is
August gone has garage full of his cars
most of them are booby-trapped but this
one in particular is his favorite I can
bypass this is the little hacking
minigame but since since Yeti is has a
submaster programmer mobility he can Pat
bypass any hack in the game so that hood
ornament that's actually his microphone
isn't that if you look at that you'll
see you'll see later in the demo that
hood ornament is actually a microphone
that you okay yeah he's a little full of
himself as you can see put it off on his
own cars alright so this seems like a
like a Time Trial kind of race yeah so
what other kind of like a minigame how
what are the kind of minigames a week so
there's the hacking minigame that we saw
there's there's racing additionally
Legion has a lot of activity that they
have going on around the world that's
not related to the the overall like main
plot that they're they're doing and
you're you're you go around basically
trying to thwart those those little
things and you get you know rewards for
those that you can use for crafting and
improving your agents can you talk a
little bit more about the other
lieutenants from what I've seen there's
some pretty interesting
characterizations that sort of I guess
mirrors the actual agents themselves
yeah I mean gaunt is definitely more on
the flamboyant side they're not all
quite to that level but early on you
fight against a weapons manufacturer
named hammer Smith he's he's a basically
you know specializes in traps and
weapons he fires beams from a satellite
from space
he also has a weapon that he's very
proud of that he gets the fire off his
balls and he's very excited about all
that um then we also have a kpop star
that is a also AI hologram oh yeah
steel-toe who sort of a transhumanist
he's a cyborg and and then dr. babylon
himself who's you know the minister of
pride and really interested in robotics
and he is he actually works for the
Morningstar who you don't really get to
meet very much in this game but he's
doing something for the Morningstar here
in Seoul sound like a newspaper yeah um
and I think I recall that the one the
leaders of the agents used to be a
former lieutenant that's right
Persephone is the leader of mayhem she
actually did work for Legion but then
when found out that they were really
more interested in destroying things
rather than taking over she's like I'm
done with that so she left she steals
technology that lets the agents of
mayhem teleport around the world which
gives them an edge but because she is
herself as sort of an ambiguous
background the agents are not
necessarily like good guys they're
really there to stop Legion not not to
necessarily save the planet so a lot of
times you end up killing civilians which
we probably end up doing here in the
station but that's okay because that's
not their job
who's mixer that keep I can see him
popping up in it yeah so along with
Persephone there are several other
agents that work at the base the mark
that we started at the beginning and the
we have like gremlin who basically
builds all the technology mixer who runs
the VR rec room but he's also sort of a
DJ so he and gaunt have a little bit of
a rivalry and they they know each other
and then we have Claymore who's the
weapon specialist in quarter-mile
quarter-mile who's in charge of all the
vehicle Bay all right so this is the
mini game yes this is the hacking mini
game thanks perfect hack yep but if I
did what if we'll wanted to make it easy
for himself he would have picked the
other character to do it yeah well well
both jewel and jetty both can bite do
the bypass but you won't get the extra
xp for completing the a community or if
you buy bypass it like that
so certain enemies weak to specific
agents and huh I mean like as if so how
are you gonna figure out who you'll be
coming up against when you're sort of
picking you to take out right right
so in general when you're fighting
you're going to run across enemies that
have shield and armor
you don't need agents to that that can
deal with those but they it's definitely
helpful so for instance some of these
enemies here have shields you'll know
you'll see like a blue bar on top of
their health bar and then on the lower
right hand corner you can see the
specializations so there's two little
icons next to the pictures so yet he has
the shield breaker item icon so he's
good at enemies that have shields
there's also Armour piercers and then
the master programmer that we we saw
earlier so the idea is you don't have to
but if you take a agents that have both
the shield anti shield and anti-armor
specializations you can sort of switch
between them as you fight find the
enemies that have those strengths how do
you regain health uh by switching can be
the guys left behind sort of you look a
bit or do you have to collect so you
enemies will drop help packs you'll see
like little red crosses that will heal
your agents I just lean when they're not
active they will heal up slowly and then
if an agent actually goes down sometimes
you'll see us purple Fleur up here on on
the ground that will resurrect all your
downed agents as well as fill up your
mayhem bar which is sort of your agents
ultimate ability yeah those now mayhem
bar also fills by using their special
abilities and killing enemies what's the
most outlandish sort of aspect of any of
the agents like in terms of powers or
abilities uh so one we like is kingpin
we don't have him in squad here but he's
a Pierce Washington from from Saints Row
and when he uses his ultimate ability he
drops a boom box in the center of the
combat area and makes all the enemies
dance so that's always a lot of fun yet
he does like this Blizzard attack that
basically freezes all the enemies around
and then you can go and shatter them I
like Daisy she's a roller blading or not
role of a roller skating
derby girl he's got a big minigun and
when you could use her mayhem ability
she goes into like certain mini gun tank
mode and just mows enemy was down now
remember the the gameplay session a
couple months ago when we did get to
play as Daisy it was a very it was an it
was a nice service mission where we
focused on her as a character as opposed
to actually taking on lieutenants right
nice break but I assume it does every
lieutenant sort of get their own time to
like you know for the player to get to
know every the agent you mean every
agent yeah yeah yeah basically every
agent has an unlock mission where before
you you get them into as a normal
playable character you play as them and
then after you've completed their unlock
machine they also have a personal
mission where you'll get more of their
backstory more about who they are why
they care about fighting against Legion
and then they also group them in three
so once you've completed the personal
missions for all three of a group you
can play a team mission together where
they you see how they work together and
sort of a larger story line there
alright I remember this thing he just to
like figure out a password yeah yeah I
think we don't really know the password
so I think we're gonna have to deal with
this guy so yeah we found out that gaunt
looks like he said some kind of rave
here in this sort of shipping containers
we have this secret club here
the gate garlic soup going on hey there
ladies and bros I want to show you
something special so wow this is the gap
Gauntlet 2.0 the VR headset in your
dreams it gives you nose it plays your
music it lets you connect to the
important people in your lives just
another slice of genius from me honorary
Doctor of Musical Arts august guns it's
a new age baby
the age
god I love y'all so much you love me
right let me hear
so here God is using his access to his
legion technology to basically brainwash
all his fans so by the end of this
mission you really really want to kill
him ya know he basically taunts you the
entire time he tries to seduce you with
his with his looks and his music and and
you're ready to go yeah opprobrium or
parties yeah they're they're coming
after you if you're not required to kill
them but some people enjoy that but
their main thing is you got to destroy
these transmitters and sort of and the
brainwashing
here you can see wheels using yetis cold
gun through the pads when it comes to
like a class-based game like this do you
look at other games I mean like
overwatch in particular it comes to mind
it has you know switching heroes and
countering and some in some cases some
similar abilities like your old gun what
do you think your place like you when
you see overwatch out there do you want
people to think we were also doing it
yeah I mean well I mean you know for us
it's more about the fact that like I I
grew up like on GI Joe and then these
kinds of stories and nobody ever made a
game where you actually play as the
heroes fighting against the villains and
I think you know that's that's one thing
that where that's what this game is
about is you get to play as these GI Joe
heroes or like let Joe Joe like heroes
but you know with more more maturity
more craziness and more and more fun so
can go in the inventory here we haven't
talked about grip from the backlog yeah
so I mentioned good before gremlin is
one of the base agency builds technology
she also builds a piece of technology
that the whole squad can use it you know
it's not a it's not specific to any
given agent so here we have what we call
the the energy skiers though basically
will trap all the all the enemies in the
area and you can basically you know
knock them around have fun but
eventually they'll just sort of
disappear and it takes here and very
quickly there these are limited use you
have you can you craft them and then you
have you can only use them so much every
time so the idea is they can kind of
give you that edge in battle but they're
not gonna yeah always you know you can't
just spam them this is a good time to
use the mayhem
yes yeah when as soon as he kills this
one here
so we get more Legion troops that show
up as well yep
I had one gallery oh honey yeah so here
only uses his ultimate so he basically
panics and fears everybody and makes
them vulnerable to his attacks and then
it's very easy to create them as well
yes what kind of other Ultimates we've
got so jewel puts down a second turret
that basically buffs her and the
battlefield and key buffs the enemies
once we have I'm sure yet second some
gather ago all right
one more pulse in my special she do all
right
yes oh he's like a blizzard and a
basically reflows and that eventually
freezes enemies
where is he a sea foam so he is actually
a Oleg from Saints Row 4 so he's from
black he's experimented on in back in in
Russia and became this sort of cold
warrior so all the agents from Saints
Row got all them don't like very much me
yeah a few of them are so like we have
Johnny Gat back like I said uh kingpin
and an Oleg are the main ones I mean I
thought your booth was any indication
with the with the magnum p.i music and
Knight Rider music I mean you guys are
really doubling down on the 80 state
what's that
always the original sort of like a like
stylistic theme game or did you like toy
around with other types of I mean it's
always been a big part of the
inspiration and it was as a matter of
like when we thought it would be good to
sort of emphasize those same sources
versus you know being more more modern
or accessible yeah it just seems to work
in the right situation so we're gonna go
for August going down around
unfortunately the demo ends before we
get to yes but the the final battle was
quite spectacular yeah well it's not
long to wait until we can get a hell
right yeah your Argos 15th well so well
thanks guys thank you so much for coming
um I hope you had a great III yes thank
you thank you so much so much and for
all the rest of to mop up everything
else from e3 make sure of course you go
to gamespot.com youtube.com slash
GameSpot we have all the biggest shows
biggest games from this year's show so
make sure you head over